bonsoir jean pierre aubry bonsoir
monsieur fillon alors pas d'entente mais
quand même est-ce que c'est le début
d'une longue négociation qui s'amorce
selon vous je pense que oui monsieur
trudeau se cantonne beaucoup dans le
court terme passer à travers la pandémie
et on va commencer des discussions pour
qu'est ce qu'on fait après ça ne pas
trop mais ce l'est des montants qui veut
mettre à moyen terme des provinces
cherche déjà à avoir une espèce de plein
ou en avait d augmentation précise oui
pour le futur monsieur trudeau est pas
là du tout mais est-ce que c'est
légitime de dire on est à 22 pour ça le
fédéral peut 20 2% des dépenses en santé
devrait monter à 35 ans a déjà été à 50
dans le passé est-ce que c'est légitime
de demander ça moi je trouve pas c'est
un service provincial et les provinces
peuvent taxer pour aller chercher
l'argent qu'ils ont besoin pour remplir
les besoins des populations
donc même coin d'impôt supplémentaire du
fédéral à ce moment là un transfert de
points d'impôt vers les provinces
ça pourrait être passé mais s'il fédéral
décide d'aller augmenter ces transferts
de façon substantielle
il devra les taxes et les gens fait que
les payeurs de taxes et l'histoire des
provinces vont leur donner cet argent
cet argent l'or et les contribuables
vont être taxés par les provinces et le
fédéral vont est extrait de l'autre
façon ça fait que au bout du compte
c'est les contribuables canadiens qui
vont payer
c'est important qu'on fasse un plan
national veut dire qu'on veut aller à
long terme le choc du vieillissement de
la population et lorgne est important
ils vont nécessiter des ressources
il faudrait qu'il y ait une entente si
possible sur le moyen et le long terme
même si elle ne fait des rallyes près
monsieur legault disait la majorité du
déficit fédéral qu'on voit en ce moment
va s'évaporer dans les prochaines années
parce que beaucoup de programmes à court
terme et même qu'il voit l'équilibré
budgétaire d'ici 10 ans au gouvernement
fédéral alors qu'il évoque déficit
structurel de 100 milliards dans les
provinces en raison de la santé
les provinces ont le fardeau des
dépenses en santé alors que le
gouvernement fédéral va pouvoir la
prochaine décennie revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire
est-ce que ça se tient sa peau aussi
fortement que les provinces le dis parce
que tout je regarde texte du directeur
parlementaire du budget oui nous disait
que fédéral serait bientôt en surplus et
il est ce plus j'ai de plus en plus
grand merci à ce prêt à ses projections
là on ajoute une dépense de 28 milliards
par année indexé à 5%
le fédéral ou d'ivoire est en déficit se
fait croquer une négociation ensemble
avec les mêmes hypothèses et prévisions
ont peu tenu compte que le vin et huet
était potes dans deux documents du
directeur parlementaire du budget et
donc le dire le directeur parlementaire
du budget fait des études sur la
viabilité viabilité financière des
gouvernements est dit que c'est viable
ce qui se passe à ottawa présentement
mais si on augmente les transferts en
santé ça sera plus viable
c'est ce que vous dites c'est vrai on
est tombé et de tout ça devienne non
viables de toutes sortes qui vaut
florent - fr les estimations mais on a
un problème pour l'ensemble des
gouvernements à savoir que les besoins
en santé vont faire qu on
besoin de plus de ressources il va
falloir décider si qui paye
mais c'est destructeur monsieur aubry
c'est la question qui va payer
parce que vous évoquez le vieillissement
de la population les les besoins en
matière de santé ne cesse d'augmenter
année après année on fait quoi
il va falloir comprendre les décisions
soient qu'on demande aux gens de
contribuer plus et ça fait du sens que
des contribuables contribuent plus
spacieux une plus grande demande le plus
de personnes âgées ou d'un autre côté on
pourrait décider de laisser tomber
d'autres dépenses qui sont moins
importants mais il ya des choix
difficiles a fallu aussi des joints au
niveau de l'environnement de soi que
plusieurs chaudes de penser qu'on va
décider juste pour les transferts la
santé et par an il faudrait lui revenait
dans deux avions nous besoin de dix
milliards au plus 15 milliards da nau se
fait que non on limite faire un plan
plus global sur plusieurs années pour
avoir une meilleure idée comment on voit
le distribuer assiette fiscale parfait
merci beaucoup monsieur aubry pour ce
tissage analyse ce soir je mentionne que
nous allons en parler dans notre ca
tantôt merci jean pierre aubry
bonsoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d
oh